[Music]  Liam Payne and Cheryl Cole call it quits  after two years of dating the former  pair who share a son together bear who  was born in March 2017 took to social  media to announce their split posting  almost identical statements quote we are  sad to announce that we are going our  separate ways it's been a tough decision  for us to make bear is our world and we  ask that you respect his privacy as we  navigate our way through this together  et caught up with the 24 year old singer  backstage in December 2017 during the  iHeartRadio Jingle Ball in New York City  where he gushed over becoming a  first-time dad and how fatherhood has  changed him oh yeah I mean in every  single way you know it's the first thing  you think about in the morning you think  about 9:00  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]